the Supreme Court comes down with an
enormous decision on LGBT issues a black
man is shot and lanta by police and new
violence breaks out and in New York
Times op ed says the quiet part out loud
I'm Ben Shapiro this is the Ben Shapiro
show today's Ben Shapiro show is
sponsored by expressive VPN your online
activity should not be public protect
yourself and express it VPN calm /ban
well we're gonna get to all of the
unrest in Atlanta we're gonna get to the
circumstances of a shooting in Atlanta
that may well end with a prosecution
although it certainly should not but we
begin at this hour with a big decision
that just came down from the Supreme
Court in which the Supreme Court has
decided without any evidence without
really any support the title 7 of the
Civil Rights Act now protects on the
basis of sexual orientation and gender
identity which is relatively insane
because title 7 obviously did not mean
and the Court acknowledges this did not
mean to deal with gay and lesbian issues
or transgender issues the notion of
gender identity was not even familiar to
people in 1964 when the Congress of the
United States was passing title 7 which
prohibits any sort of discrimination on
a federal level on the basis of race
color religion sex and national origin
now the Supreme Court is making the
absurd contention the title 7 of the
Civil Rights Act prohibits
discrimination on the basis of sexual
orientation which by the way people knew
that folks were gay and lesbian in 1964
they did not include that in title 7 not
only that but Congress has repeatedly
attempted to and failed to include
sexual orientation in updates of title 7
they failed because that's pretty
controversial stuff I mean that's
talking about for example your Catholic
hospital and now you are mandated to
violate your own religious precepts in
hiring gays and lesbians or transgender
people that is something that the the
Democratic parties have been pushing for
a very long time but it's a
controversial issue because it is not
included in title 7 title 7 was meant to
say that if you are a woman that you
cannot be prohibited against on the sole
basis that you are a woman not that you
are a gay woman for example not that you
are a gay man but on the basis that you
are a man you cannot be discriminated
against and on the basis that you are a
woman you cannot be discriminated
against well now the Supreme Court has
gone back in time and magically correct
course-corrected to include sexual
orientation and transgender identity in
federal civil rights legislation that
obviously
meant to be there so now the idea is
that if Bob walks into your place of
employment tomorrow and you're a large
company you have over 50 employees Bob
walks in your place of employ tomorrow
and he says my name is gene I wish you
to call me gene you say well Bob you
know that doesn't really fit your job
description and like that's not
something that we're ideologically okay
with here you're now in violation of
federal civil rights law right that is
the idea under this decision now there
may or may not be a an exception for
openly religious organizations so not
Catholic hospitals which do a secular
business or Catholic adoption agencies
which do a secular business but you work
for a church or you work for a Catholic
school right that may be part of the job
description is that you abide by
Catholic doctrine or Catholic teachings
but for example there are a lot of
Catholic schools that have sort of
religious studies in the morning and
then they have secular studies in the
afternoon but they also do not want
people in the afternoon courses who may
not be Catholic for example to be openly
violating certain religious precepts and
so they say listen we teach at the
school that certain types of human
activity are sinful and we don't want
our teachers engage in that
theoretically that could now be illegal
if you have a if you're a religious
person and you own a corporation you say
listen people who work at my corporation
I just don't want them participating in
certain types of activity that I don't
like well now that would be the basis
for a lawsuit what is left completely
unclear here is whether it is the basis
for a lawsuit whether let's say you
abide by this new ruling and every a
transgender person comes in you hire the
transgender person but you are a
conservative company and you say as as I
do and as dayley wire has said that a
man is a man and a woman as a woman does
that now amount to discrimination under
federal law it is not clear under this
particular provision of of the Supreme
Court decision this is a very
far-reaching decision it's a very bad
decision and the part of it that's quite
shocking is that just as corsets wrote
the decision now if you listen to the
oral arguments way back in February it
was pretty obvious which way Gorsuch was
gonna go on this thing it was pretty
obvious always were robbers who's gonna
go because Roberts is a garbage justice
but Gorsuch was widely perceived to be a
textualist his attempt to shoehorn
textualism into this decision is insane
I mean it's really wild because the fact
is that what a textualist would do or an
originalist
is they would read the text of the of
the statutes and look at the meaning of
the statute at the time and say what it
meant or what it did not mean they would
not say Oh
we've updated the wording now so now it
means something completely different
than what it meant back in 1964 but
that's exactly what Gorsuch does here so
Gorsuch says we agree that homosexuality
and transgender status are distinct
concepts from sex okay that should be
the end of the inquiry right once you
say that homosexuality and transgender
status are not sex right that's a
completely different concept then you
have to make the argument that
presumably the Civil Rights Act of 1964
talks about discrimination on the basis
of sex not on the basis of homosexuality
or transgender status or sexual
orientation or any of that right but
says Gorsuch as we've seen
discrimination based on homosexuality or
transgender status necessarily entails
discrimination based on sex the first
cannot happen without the second nor is
there any such thing as a canon of
doughnut holes in which Congress's
failure to speak directly to a specific
case that falls within a more general
statutory rule creates a tacit exception
okay that's not true at all
okay if it is perfectly obvious that
Congress has repeatedly attempted to
fill a doughnut and that doughnut has
not been filled and it's pretty obvious
that Congress itself perceived that the
doughnut had not been filled in other
words it's not that Congress created
this overarching penumbra and emanation
that the Supreme Court was supposed to
fill in the idea instead was that
Congress was being very specific about
what it wished to prohibit you have a
job all you know about the applicants is
that one is a man and one is a woman you
cannot discriminate solely on the basis
of sex right you cannot discriminate on
the basis of sex in that decision
now as Justice Alito points out in his
dissent it doesn't make any logical
sense what what what Gorsuch and the
majority do here right so Gorsuch says
sexual harassment is conceptually
distinct from sex discrimination but it
can fall within title 7 sweep would the
employers have us reverse those cases on
the theory that Congress could have
spoken to those problems more
specifically of course not as enacted
Title 7 prohibits all forms of
discrimination because of sex however
they may manifest themselves or whatever
other labels might attach to them so in
other words what he is saying is that
sexual orientation is covered by the
prohibition to discriminate on the basis
of sex because you couldn't be
homosexual without being a member of the
same sex as the person to whom you are
engaging in sex right so in other words
if woman has sex with the man then and
is not fired but a man has sex of the
man and is fired it is not sexual
orientation that is the question
but the
of the man but as Justice Alito points
out that makes no sense because you
could very easily have a policy that
says a woman cannot have sex with a
woman and a man cannot have sex with a
man again by the way this is not to make
the case that people should not hire gay
men or gay women this is me talking
about whether you are forced by law to
hire people right whether you are forced
by law that is a different question it's
what I would do in a business
circumstance I'm sure there are people
who are gay and lesbian who are working
for my company right now I don't care
and frankly if somebody applied as a
transgender person I wouldn't care about
that either
okay the reality is that I'll hire
anybody of any time so long as they can
do the job I really don't care but that
is not the question here the question is
whether the federal government can
compel businesses to violate freedom of
association to violate freedom of
religious liberty to violate freedom of
speech and you watch this decision
ironically enough will then be used as a
social media Club with which to beat
everyone who says things like men and
women exist so decision which basically
says that anything that manifests
manhood or womanhood is now violative of
federal law if you fire somebody on that
basis or discriminate on that basis that
will be used as they caused by social
media within the next six months watch
to say that if you say a man is a man
and a woman as a woman you are now
discriminating on the basis of
transgender identity which ironically
enough is rejected by the court here
because if the court is actually saying
is that it is a discrimination against a
man if you fire him on the basis of
transgender identity so a man comes in
dressed as a woman and you say to him
well you're not a woman
so I'm firing you that is a
discrimination based on sex according to
the Supreme Court of the United States
okay which overtly rejects I mean that
that implicitly and overtly rejects the
idea that a man who comes in and says
that he is a woman is actually a woman
right because then it wouldn't be
discrimination on the basis of sex it
would be discrimination on the basis of
something else so logically speaking
there are a lot of holes in this
argument as Alito makes clear in his
dissent it is unclear what the
ramifications of the Supreme Court
decision today are going to be it really
is not particularly clear what is clear
is that if you're a religious person in
the United States and you owned a
company then this is a very big problem
for you if you actually hope to use any
sort of religious values traditional
religious values and you're hiring right
there is something called the Hobby
Lobby case and how better closely
corporation like Hobby Lobby could not
provide for abortion care in its
healthcare coverage right so now under
under this Supreme Court decision could
have closely held religious corporations
say listen we don't employ them employ
gays and lesbians because we're
religious Christian family we don't want
to do that or could they say we don't
want to employ people who are
transgender because it violates our
perspective on what males and females
are right all of that is left up in the
air by this decision also left up in the
air is what does discrimination
constitute so as I say I'll hire anybody
at my company but I will say on the air
that a man is a man and a woman is a
woman well let's say I say that just
around the office let's say I'm talking
to some people around the office and I'm
talking politics and I say a man is a
man and a woman is a woman and a
transgender person over here is that
have I now created a discriminatory work
environment utterly unclear from this
decision utterly unclear from this
decision so the decision creates an
enormous number of questions it is
legally ridiculous not only is it
legally ridiculous it does give the lie
to the idea that conservatives can
simply rely on these on the federal
courts of the United States to protect
them and this has been one of the great
lies that conservatives have pushed for
years all we need to do in Congress is
give you tax cuts and judges and then
and then you should be happy with that
okay two of the judges voted for this
thing too the judges vote for this very
very bad decision on a legal basis two
of those judges are Republicans two of
those were appointed by Republicans
Roberts and gore such are they're only
for Democratic appointees who voted for
this decision this thing went six three
so once again Republicans proving
themselves incompetent at selecting
Supreme Court judges I'm old enough to
remember when but Gorsuch was the big
excuse for you have to back Trump
because but Gorsuch gore such was the
opinion writer in this particular case
by the way worth noting this is the same
Supreme Court that has turned down
multiple writs of certiorari writs of
cert our applications for a Supreme
Court case on the second amendment so
the Supreme Court will not decide
basically the Supreme Court has
established a federal right for you to
own a gun in your home but the Supreme
Court has not decided whether you can
carry whether they can have a gun in
your business and they've rejected every
case on that basis Second Amendment
cases they're rejecting right and left
but they certainly took up a case in
which they basically established that if
you fire somebody on the basis of your
own religious conviction and you're not
no vertel religious organization then
you can be federally sued under the
federal Civil Rights Act of 1964 without
any additional legislation even though
it is clear to everyone right
Center that the 64 Civil Rights Act did
not covered this sort of activity it
obviously did not okay like the this is
perfectly clear Gorsuch admits as much
he just expands it okay that's bad law
and it's once again proof that if you're
relying on judges to save you from the
from the elements of left good good luck
good luck it ain't gonna happen okay
we're gonna get to the complete
breakdown of law and order in the United
States in just one moment first let's
talk about something brighter the
possibility of investing in cool
companies
imagine having a convenient tabletop
device that gives complete lab grade
blood count results in minutes with
nothing but a small prick in two drops
of blood no more having to draw vials of
blood only to wait days for critical
test results this is the future of blood
testing there's a company called site
that has announced that it is here you
could invest in site Diagnostics in the
future of easier faster blood testing at
our crowd comm this is what our crowd
comm does they spot awesome
up-and-coming companies and they allow
you to invest really early in those
companies our crowds crowdsourced
investing platform gets accredited
investors access to early-stage funding
rounds in some of the most promising
companies around the world they help you
invest before the companies go public
like they have with a company called
beyond meat they've also invested in
almost 200 companies today our crab bat
companies have been bought by Nike
Oracle uber Comcast Intel snap and more
getting in on the ground floor when your
investor is a boon so you can check out
those possibilities right now at our
crowd really is exciting stuff learn
more about investing in companies like
site Diagnostics at info our crowd comm
slash Shapiro again that's info dot our
crowd comm slash at Shapiro info dot our
crowd oh you are CRO d.com slash CRO you
CRO wdu rather dot-com slash appear are
setting up the account is free that's
our crowd oh you are CRO WD comm slash
pro info our crowd comm slash Shapiro
it's a bit of a long addressing to make
after I repeat it see I'll get it info
our crowd comm slash up here I'll go
check them out right now
okay so meanwhile and we are still
looking at the at the incredible
extension of civil rights law in an area
where it had never been presumed to be
extended before by the Supreme Court
well look more at the at the sort of
ramifications of that as we continue
because I've been waiting through one
seventy pages of legal opinion we'll get
to that in a moment but first let's talk
about what's been going on in Atlanta so
be continued attack on the police it's
it's ongoing and it's going to have real
ramifications so over the weekend there
was a flare-up in Atlanta the flare-up
in Atlanta was essentially a a man who
was apparently asleep at a drive-thru at
Wendy's because he was drunk behind the
wheel the police show up and they start
questioning him the questioning list for
25 minutes they're very polite he's
fairly polite to them then when they go
to arrest him he starts to resist arrest
not only does he resist arrest he knocks
down two of the police officers he grabs
one of their tasers and then he as he's
running away from the officers he turns
around in points the officers taser at
the officer and attempts to fire it at
the officer at which point the officer
shoots him dead
so we have the actual footage of this it
is disturbing so if you're disturbed by
this sort of footage then you should
probably skip the next minute and a half
or so here is what the actual situation
was because this is being used as yet
another case in point of evil brutal
white police taking down an innocent
black man and that is not what this case
is not all cases are created equivalent
this is not like the case of George
Floyd it is not this is not like a case
about Matar berry okay this is a case
which a person stole a weapon off a cop
and pointed the weapon at the cop and
then he was shot dead so here is what
the this resulted by the way in the
burning down of the Wendy's which makes
no sense it's not the Wendy's fault by
the way it's a white chick apparently
who burned down the Wendy's we'll get to
that in a second but the here was the
actual footage and it's important to
analyze these situations because the
headlines that came from the media were
just a lie like an overt lie there were
headlines from the media that said
things like unarmed black man shot by
police he was not unarmed he was
literally holding the Taser and pointing
it at the officer at the time okay here
is what the footage look like and I'll
narrate it for people who can't actually
see it I wasn't here so can you tell me
what what happened before we got here
okay so they're giving him the the
walking test he obviously can't can't
walk in a straight line he's having
trouble this guy's very okay I mean what
kind of drinks did you I'm not sure if
some she orders she said top-shelf or
whatever
top-shelf one I'm not sure it was like I
said they're talking drinks that he's
had this is all very polite right I mean
if the police officers are out to kill
the guy
this is not how that encounter starts
typically it's white racist police
officers looking to kill black man you
usually don't have 25 okay now here's
what gets ugly so they go to handcuff
the guy fade the body cam footage is
here and then next you cut to footage
from somebody else now the guys were
resisting arrest he takes these guys to
the police officers to ground he reaches
out he steals the Taser from one of the
police officers and they're shouting
he's got my taser he's got my taser
right one of the officers draws his
taser trying tase him up it apparently
fails the guy the guy grabs the taser
from him escapes the police officers and
takes off down the street I think you'll
see him throw the police officer in one
second and finally kind of bust free of
them and run okay he tries to tase him
there right he tries to he points it at
the officer there then he's running away
he turns around and he fires the Taser
at the police officer at which point the
police officer shoot him okay so this
yeah I asked several police officers
last night I want to make sure that I
was getting this right right because I
don't know police procedure
I read the law in the city of Atlanta on
use of deadly force and this falls
squarely within the law on the use of
deadly force if someone removes a weapon
from a police officer and fires it at
the police officer if it is a Taser so
people were saying idiotic things they
were suggesting that well you know a
Taser isn't a deadly weapon so you can't
shoot the guy for use it well no the
idea is that he's already demonstrated
his willingness to take a weapon off an
officer if he fires the Taser at the
officer and takes the officer down
what is to prevent him from then going
over to the officer withdrawing the
officer's gun and shooting him the
officer does not have to wait around to
be killed that is not the way this works
the officer does not have to
around to be seriously injured by a
suspect to his resisting arrest so the
Atlanta mayor immediately fired this
officer immediately okay and said that
while this was just because this was
justified by law doesn't mean it was
justified in action in other words yes
the law covers this sort of activity by
police officers because again I talked
to multiple police officers not a single
one of these police officers thought
this is a bad shoot because it isn't a
bad shoot if you knock down police
officers and you steal a weapon off a
police officer and then you fire a
weapon at a police officer even if it is
a Taser they are not obligated to shoot
to wound because that's not a thing they
have to stop you you're running away
with a police officers taser right now
and he again by the way they don't shoot
him as he but before he turns around and
attempts to shoot them with the Taser
and he turns around he fires the Taser
you can see it you can see the Taser
light up as he attempts to fire it at
them in the footage here's the Atlanta
mayor firing the guy and now the DA is
considering prosecuting the guy
prosecuting the cop so here's the
Atlanta mayor while there may be debate
as to whether this was an appropriate
use of deadly force I firmly believe
that there is a clear distinction
between what you can do and what you
should do I do not believe that this was
a justified use of deadly force and have
called for the immediate termination of
the officer okay so it is so there's a
distinction to what you can do and what
you should do I'd like to see her on the
street actually policing if you're
police officer what are you supposed to
do sit around until somebody kills you
until someone gravely injuries you I
guess that is the idea here from so many
people so the attorney for the family
here he says well you know Taylor isn't
a deadly weapon a Taser is in a deadly
weapon again if a if a person approaches
you with a baseball bat you do know it
is quite possible but the first blow of
the baseball bat is not going to kill
you but if they approach you with a
weapon you are justified in shooting by
the way if they charge you and you don't
have and the person does not have a
weapon if they charge you with intent to
do bodily harm you don't have to wait
there until they actually physically
assault you that is not a thing it's
certainly not a thing when they're
firing a Taser at you but here was the
lawyer for the man who was killed in in
Atlanta whose name was Brooks the case
law in Georgia that tasers not a deadly
weapon
so they can't say it's not like he was
running off with a gun it's not a deadly
weapon
I I lose cases against officers who use
it on my clients because it's not a
deadly weapon and I'm saying that you
know they should have done it but you
just can't have it both ways in this if
it's not a deadly weapon his life was
not in immediate harm when he fired that
shot um well I don't know I mean its
immediate harm like his life is not an
immediate heart the guy turned around
and fired taser at him you don't get to
do that to police officers without fear
of being shot right we hear a lot about
the talk which a lot of parents give
their kids particularly the black
community apparently this is a talk that
happens a lot where you tell your kids
you know be careful around police
because they might shoot you well part
of that talk is respect the respect the
orders of the officer I'm pretty sure
that this does not fall under the
behavior that is usually covered by that
talk okay again every police officer
that I have talked to says this is a
good shoot every single one I talk to
multiple of them yesterday so if you
don't like this sort of thing and you
don't have to like it but if you don't
if you don't acknowledge this sort of
thing is covered by normal police
officer behavior then you really
shouldn't be in charge of police policy
you really should not hey you had james
Clyburn for the abhi congressman from
South Carolina he said this didn't call
for lethal force again like I don't know
who are what what the policing
background is of the people who are
saying that if a person steals a Taser
off another off a police officer after
downing two police officers and then
fires it the police officer and gets
shot in the process but that doesn't
call for lethal force or at least allow
for the application of lethal force this
did not call for be full force and I
don't know what's in the culture that
would make this guy do that it has got
to be the culture it's got to be the
system you gather after the American
woman there you got a woman police chief
so the sensitivity is that we look for
in people over there but it's not
ingrained in the institution Awesome's
the institution you see it's the
institution again 25 minutes
back-and-forth with a guy before he
resists arrest and steals a weapon off a
police officer and tries to shoot
with a Taser so now the DEA I mean this
is how politicized this has gotten the
Fulton District Attorney Paul Howard
said his office will decide this week of
care at Roth the guy who was fired
following the shooting will be charged
in the case
he said that could mean a murder charge
Howard said quote Brooks did not seem to
present any kind of threat to anyone any
kind of threat to anyone he literally
down two police officers right he he
took them to the ground you can see it
in the tape and then he fires a Taser at
one of them he attempts to fire it at
him again right twice he says the fact
it would escalate to his death it seems
unreasonable if that shot was fired for
some reason other than to save that
officer's life or prevent injury to him
or others prevent injury to him or
others is the operative language if
someone fires our taser me I'm pretty
much going to assume they intend injury
to me or others the shooting is not
justified under the law says this da I
mean this is this is insanity like it
truthfully to prosecute a cop on these
charges is full-scale insanity it's
crazy but this is the world that we are
creating for police officers and it's
gonna have predictable results which is
police officers are gonna quit and
you're gonna see what a world without
police look like really who'd want to
serve under these circumstances there
are actual ramifications - the police
are all racist and all evil it is one
thing to say that you want to curb
police brutality it is another thing to
say that in circumstances that justify a
shooting legally speaking that you're
gonna go after the police anyway because
now you've just made policing basically
undoable and that's what many police
officers recognized by the way I talk to
a lot of cops about the shooting
yesterday and nearly all of them also
said at least for once a major city I'm
looking for a way to get out of the
police force because this is not a way
that I can survive I can't keep my
family under these circumstances I'm
supposed to brick off the head rather
than do anything about it
I I can't I can't do that I'll get a
security job somewhere we'll talk more
about this in just one second first
let's talk about the fact that if you
are web browsing without a VPN to
protect your information that is a risky
thing to do and in most you're probably
thinking why don't you just use
incognito mode well incognito mode does
not hide your activity it doesn't matter
what mode you use or how many times you
clear your browsing history your ISP can
still see every single website you've
ever visited which is why even when I'm
at home I never go online without using
it Express at VPN it doesn't matter if
you get your internet from Verizon or
Comcast or anywhere else ISPs in the
u.s. can legally sell your information
to add companies which is sort of the
opposite of what you want to happen when
you are online right you want that
information to be yours and yours alone
expressvpn is an app that reroutes your
internet
connection through their secure servers
so your ISP can't see the sites you
visit expressvpn also keeps all of your
information secure by encrypting 100% of
your data with the most powerful
encryption available most of the time I
didn't realize I have expressvpn running
it runs seamlessly in the background my
computer
right one click of the button and now
it's running protect it your online
activity today with the VPN rated number
1 by C net and wired you can visit my
exclusive link expressvpn comm slash
been me an extra three months for free
on a one-year package also prevents
people from hacking you and stealing
your information check them out and
express it VPN comm slash bandits exp
ress VPN comm slash been to learn more
expressvpn dot-com slash then ok so
meanwhile speaking of areas that have
gone completely capless exciting news
from the republic of chas
it's the republic of jazz man they've
actually changed their name now they
took my advice they said they decided
the republic of Chaz's a bad name so now
they've actually gone literal the
republic of chop the capitol hill
organized protest that is what they're
calling themselves chop so it's good
when they bring the guillotines out at
least they'll know that vance noticed
everybody
according to KO mo news without a leader
and with more voices chiming in some of
the protesters that have been pushing
for police reform and advocating for
black lives matter at the now abandoned
East precinct states a move to get the
movement back on track the name Chaz we
didn't actually come up with that said a
protester we're not sure if it was
detractors or people trying to push a
false narrative they came in with that
name they came in with the signs oh it
was the right it was probably us is
probably people on the right who called
the Chaz not that people call it called
it the capitol hill autonomous zone
ok so Chaz has turned into a garbage
heap naturally we have footage of what
this area of Seattle looks like is
graffiti strewn hell hole I mean it's
really really bad they've repeated every
building they've graffiti to every
window they've broken some of the
windows as well it's really nice looking
right I mean this this looks good
it says justice for all looters people
have spray-painted on windows they're
giant bags of trash everywhere the all
cops are bad that's a cab if you're
seeing a cab that means all cops are bad
which is a hell of a take abolish
Seattle PD
police aren't domestic terrorists right
they've graffiti to every sit in there
in Arcis symbols and then of course the
odd genitalia which is which is very
important you have
make sure that you have a graffitied on
something in order for you to really
this free to really make a difference in
in American life so the things are also
not going well in terms of the the
actual governance the Chas protesters
actually had to call the fire department
after a dumpster fire was started just
outside the boundary of Chas according
to Chas protesters in Seattle had been
camped out this week in an enclave
called Chas and apparently they
apparently a fire was started just
outside Chas and so they called the fire
department about the dumpster fire
which again is a very very good
indicator of exactly what Chas is
they've been trying to grow their own
crop they're not particularly autonomous
and try and grow their own crop I will
say they could use a few Republicans in
there with their gardening their
gardening on cement they took some
topsoil they put it on top of cardboard
and now they're trying to garden on the
top soil which is placed on top of
cardboard which look it looks great
looks great guys I'm sure that your
bumper crop will be coming up any time
also freedom is flourishing over in Chas
certainly advocates who are not black
actually are trying to push all of the
white people in Chas to give $10 to
their black neighbors on the basis of
race so racial discrimination is like
first step in Chas this is exciting
stuff this I want you to give $10 to one
african-american person from this
autonomous zone and if you find that's
difficult if you find this hard for you
to give $10 to people of color to black
people especially you have to think
really critically about in the future
are you gonna actually give up power and
land and capital what you have it things
are going great over in Chas so we have
full on racial redistribution happening
also if you're black and are carrying an
American flag that's bad so we're
allowed to we're allowed to have the
cops of Chas go after it the American
flag is banned in Chad's that's exciting
stuff Andy our friend Dan you know who
reports from these sorts of situations
there's a black guy who's walking
through Chas carrying American flag and
people tried to steal the flag from him
which of course things are going great
there they're shouting at him they're
chasing him down the street it's good
times it's good times so excellent
excellent news also the the Chaz
protesters were threatening street
preachers so things are going great
there they have their own police force
that basically is just an arm band that
goes around and threatens people which
is exciting stuff they have a border
they they have not been enforcing the
law they've tripled the 9-1-1 time
according to the Seattle PD if
somebody's got a problem inside Chas so
things are going beautifully inside
chest meanwhile over in Portland
protesters shut down the street again
because Portland has been again one of
these cities that has been left to the
tender mercies of aunt Eva the point in
all this is that when you chase away the
cops and when you tell them they can't
do their jobs things get worse they do
not get better and they get they get
worse particularly in high crime
communities I'm gonna bring you the
evidence of that in just one second
because as we hear defunding the police
from all the morons as we here get rid
of the police abolish the police from
all the idiots recognize that has
real-world ramifications for an enormous
number of actual human beings we're
gonna get to that in just one second
first let's talk about how you make your
business better I'm talking about
NetSuite by Oracle it's the world's
number one cloud business system listen
you need to be on top of your data
particularly these days in a volatile
business climate finance HR inventory
e-commerce everything you need all in
one place you save time money headaches
whether you're doing a million or
hundreds of millions in sales
NetSuite will give you visibility and
control so you can manage every penny
with precision joy number 20,000
companies you trust in that suite to go
faster with confidence NetSuite has
surveyed hundreds of business leaders
assembled a playbook of the top
strategies they are using as America
reopens for business listen as you are
running your business you're gonna need
to know everything you can about your
business because any inefficiency is
gonna cost you on the bottom line and it
could cost your business this is why you
must be on top of your business you have
to have all your business systems
integrated and this is why you need
NetSuite by Oracle receive your free
guide seven actions businesses need to
take now and schedule your free product
store at NetSuite calm slash up Shapiro
again get your free guide scheduling a
free product or RightNow and NetSuite
comm slash up Shapiro that is NEETs uit
e.com @ / up hero NetSuite comm slash
your peril go check them out right now
NetSuite comm / up hero and get your
free guide seven actions businesses need
to take now and schedule your free at
product or at NetSuite com
/ appear oh right now okay so all of
this has a national impact so there's
this bizarre idea like the the wife of
Bill DeBlasio whose name escapes me from
the moment who may run for mayor herself
apparently which would just be wonderful
cuz he's been so great she said that she
looks forward to in New York without
police that would actually be some sort
of paradise chef she says she suggested
would be nirvana would be nirvana
without police well what happens to
towns without police well Roland fryer
and researchers at Harvard University
have just come out the study and here's
what they found
they found that after federal
investigations against police officers
in areas with a disputed attack so for
example Ferguson what they saw is that
after federal investigations and heavy
media exposure
you know what cops do they stop policing
because they recognize that they are now
on the chopping block so this is not an
excuse for police brutality but it is to
recognize that when you sick the entire
media establishment and law enforcement
establishment on itself and when instead
of being deliberate and how you attempt
to change policy you with a blunderbuss
basically fire a police officers and say
that all police are racist a cab all
police are bad when you do that from
public policy level what you end up
doing is telling the police not to do
the policing and then what happens crime
Rises dramatically so according to this
new study from Roland fryer four
investigations that were preceded by a
viral incidence of deadly force
Baltimore Chicago Cincinnati Riverside
and Ferguson there's a market increase
in both homicide and total crime the
cumulative amount of crime that we
estimate due to pattern or practice
investigations in the two years after
the announcement for this sample is 21
point 10 per 100,000 for homicides and
1191 point 77 per 100,000 for felony
total crime put plainly the casual the
causal effects of the investigations in
these five cities trigger mainly by the
deaths of Freddie gray laQuan McDonald
Timothy Thomas nyesha Miller and Michael
Brown at the hands of police has
resulted in 893 more homicides than
would have been expected with no
investigation in more than thirty three
thousand four hundred seventy two
additional felony crimes relative to
synthetic control cities so in other
words nine hundred more people died
because you decided that you're going to
go after police departments in all of
these areas by the way predominantly
minority police departments in the case
of Baltimore to get a sense of how large
this number is again this is study from
Roland fryer another research
at Harvard the average number of fatal
shootings of african-americans by police
officers in Baltimore Chicago Cincinnati
Riverside and st. Louis per year is 12
thus even if investigations cured these
cities of all future civilian casualties
at the hands of police it would take
approximately 75 years to break even our
estimate suggests that investigating
police departments after viral incidents
of police violence is responsible for
approximately 450 excess homicides per
year this is 2 times the loss of life in
the line of duty for u.s. military in a
year 12 point six times the annual loss
of life due to school shootings and
three times the loss of life due to
lynchings between 1882 and 1901 the most
gruesome years so in other words when
you crack down on the police and you
tell them not to do their jobs there's a
predictable result and the predictable
result is a lot more crime a lot more
crime but we are going to pretend that
that doesn't exist because it's more
important to label the police who are
saving black lives as we speak as racist
very very important stuff this is how
you end up with a column by Miriam
Miriam Makeba organized her against
criminalization in the New York Times
remember that time when the New York
Times said it wasn't going to run op eds
that were poorly thought out in the wake
of Tom cotton op eds that were sneering
in tone wait till you hear this one
we'll get to it in just one second first
let's talk about a great gift for
father's day so as you know I'm a watch
guy I really love watches and I like
given watches to my friends and family
birthdays and anniversaries and Father's
Day is a great opportunity to give your
dad a great watch but you don't wanna
break the bank you don't wanna spend
thousands of dollars on a watch instead
go check out VIN Cheryl watches these
are watches I love to wear it I'm a
luxury watch guy my listeners already
know that VIN cherrylle creates the most
incredible looking watches an amazing a
price point these are seriously stunning
watches well under $200 there's no
better gift for a dad a husband
grandfather you name it then giving them
the gift of time with a venture Oh watch
during this time they continued to do
right by their buyers they know how
important it is to have a great watch
for an affordable price go check them
out at VIN Cheryl watches comm slash
Schapiro that's a VI n c ro watches comm
slash shapiro they offer free shipping
30-day returns guarantee or watch for
two years they have over 21,000
five-star reviews because they're great
it's a watch that stylish bold built to
last have a bunch of at different
options my wife wears of inch arrow
every day and you can engrave at the
back of the watch to actually have one
that's engraved with facts don't care
take advantage of their sale get up to
20% off everything
on their website none of the new items
are off-limits they have brand new watch
collections you need to see for yourself
online right now vin charile watches
dot-com / apparel when you purchase the
discount is automatically applied at
checkout the 20% off go check them out
vin cherrylle watches comm / shapiro for
20% off ok we're gonna get to the call
to abolish the police and then we will
get to the insane hypocrisy of democrats
when it comes to kovat lock downs
because it is just growing day on day
first you may have noticed this this
year is totally insane it's like all the
storylines decided to converge this year
the writers just they opened up all of
the all of the old files and just dumped
out all the unused storylines in 2020
well if you want actual real media
coverage of what exactly is going on you
need a reader's pass today from daily
wire.com you'll get access to exclusive
op-eds from us your podcast host as well
as guest writers and in-depth analysis
from our daily wire reporters on top of
regular breaking news this membership
tier is already a bargain at 3 bucks a
month but if you join today you get your
first month for $0.99 you also get
access to our mobile app and receive
push notifications for breaking news and
special content as well as joining the
community of daily wear members or
actively commenting and discussing our
content with each other that is mobile
ad free access to all of the daily wear
news exclusive op-eds and all of our
podcasts on our mobile app all for the
low price of $1 and best of all your
Bucks are getting you the news you need
with no left to spin head on over to
daily wear cons flash subscribe and join
today also now would be a great time to
preorder my new book how to destroy
America in three easy steps are watching
it happen in real time as all of the
ideas that used to unify us ideas about
Liberty ideas about equality before the
law all these are thrown out in favor of
identity politics my book talks about
the destruction of America's common
philosophy history and culture and how
to stop it really it's a
counter-argument to the 16 19 project
it's a counter arguments the identity
politics of the of the left and the
socialist politics of Bernie Sanders I
think it's really important book and I
think you'll really get a lot from it go
check it out today how to destroy
America in three easy steps you can
pre-order at daily wire.com slash
bending and that's daily wire.com slash
bend to get my brand-new book comes out
July 21st you can pre-order and now
daily we're calm /ban you're listening
to the largest fastest growing
conservative podcast and radio show in
the nation
[Music]
you
so you remember that time that bunch
people who left said defund the police
and then never wasn't we don't mean the
fun the police we just mean like move
some of the money to mental health and
move it to educational programs and
midnight basketball well now they're
just like nah now you know we actually
meant abolish the police Miriam Kaba
organized her against criminalization as
a piece in The New York Times titled yes
we mean literally abolish the police
because reform won't happen by the way
this is not a rear perspective Ilhan
omar has said the same thing
Ilhan omar the congresswoman from
minnesota she said the central polish
the police department because you cannot
reform a rotten department here was
congressman omar a new way forward can't
be put in place if we have a department
that is having a crisis of credibility
if we have a department that's led by a
chief who suited for racism if we have a
department that hasn't solved homicide
half of the homicides in minneapolis
police department go unsolved there have
been cases where they destroyed rape
kits and so you can't really reform a
department that that is rotten to to the
root what you can do is rebuild okay so
that's exciting stuff we can rebuild the
police department but how the hell you
gonna rebuild the police department
while you're telling everybody that if
they defend themselves are gonna
prosecute them which is essentially what
major police departments around the
united states are now telling people
what they actually wanted to is abolish
and so miriam Kaba
she writes congressional democrats want
to make it easier to identify and
prosecute police misconduct joe biden
wants to give police departments three
hundred million dollars but efforts to
solve police violence through liberal
reforms like these have failed for
nearly a century
enough we can't reform the police the
only way to diminish police violence is
to reduce contact between the public and
the police by the way she's right about
that
the way to diminish police violence is
to reduce contact between the public and
police there two ways to go about that
one is to reduce the police which
results in an increase in crime the
other is to increase the police and
reduce the crime rate because it turns
out you don't have as many encounters
with the cops when you are not actually
committing a crime the cops are there to
police crime they're not there to just
screw you screw with you because of your
race contrary to popular perception
according to this this idiot person
there's not a single era in US history
in which the police were not a force of
violence against black people police
the South emerged from the slave patrols
in the 1700's and 1800's that caught and
returned runaway slaves in the North the
first few minutes municipal police
departments in the mid-1800s helped
squash labor strikes and riots against
the rich everywhere they've suppressed
marginalized populations to protect the
status quo well I mean first of all just
because police departments did very bad
things and you know 1700 does not mean
that they are doing very bad things in
2020 like saving black lives that's not
a bad thing and they are doing it every
single day in black communities all over
the United States as that Harvard study
that I just - you suggest but the idea
here from this woman is that anytime you
see a police officer pressing his knee
into a black man's neck until he dies
that is the logical result of policing
in America now again you're gonna have
to explain me how that's the logical
result of policing in America when
removing the police results in literally
an exponential increase in murder in the
black community how is that so according
to this woman the idea is that police
officers don't do what you think they do
they spend most of their time responding
to noise complaints issuing parking and
traffic citations dealing with other non
criminal issues we've been taught to
think they catch the bad guys chase bank
robbers find serial killers but that's a
myth the vast majority of police
officers make one felony arrest a year
if they make to their cop of the month
well yes because having police in
communities actually means that you're
stopping the crime before it occurs
right that is why you have to look at
excess deaths it's not as though there's
a certain number of murders and then the
police to ferret out the murderers and
that's how you stop this thing police if
police are in a particular area people
don't murder people as much in that area
because they are afraid of getting
caught
but apparently abolishing the police is
gonna be better for black Americans they
say police officers break rules all the
time and because police officers break
rules all the time
that means the reform will be completely
a failure my favorite part of this
article is where this particular
columnist suggests that you don't need
police officers to investigate rape
quote what about rape the current
approach has intended it in fact most
rapists never see the inside of a
courtroom two-thirds of people who
experience sexual violence never report
it to anyone those who filed police
reports are often dissatisfied with the
response okay you have still not
suggested in an actual way that you're
going to police rape in the absence of
the police you just said police are not
good enough at policing rape but saying
the quiet part out loud I mean I'm all
for it honestly like you want to say the
quiet part out loud please
please continue please go for it the
policies that are being pushed by
Democrats here are in the end it really
is not a policy it is just a message and
the message is that racism and bigotry
are baked into our institutions that is
a case that Mitch Landrieu the the mayor
of New Orleans has has suggested he says
racism is baked into our institutions as
Mitch Landrieu it is clear that white
people in America don't have a real
understanding or don't really believe
that racism is institutionalized and
when they hear it they don't
particularly understand what it is they
think that we're calling every white
person in America racist and it's the
exact opposite
it's biases that are baked into the
institutions that when applied equally
and unequally have a disparate impact on
african-americans african-americans on
the other hand understand clearly what
institutional racism is ok so this is
this is the narrative right then by the
way so there's Mitch Landrieu on stir to
understand the institutional racism
because he's whiter he's as white as the
day is long
apparently he doesn't understand
institutional racism so it's all about
the narrative it's all about the
narrative and here's the thing the
narrative has no limits because once you
suggest that Western civilization and
its institutions are shot through with
racism and evil and there is no end to
the iconoclasm there's no end to the
statues you want to tear down over in
Britain thanks to these protests they're
trying to remove the statue of Winston
Churchill from the public gaze right the
guy who saved Britain during World War
two and want to remove his statue all of
these losers who live in their mothers
basements and who feel very righteous
when they tweet things on Twitter and
they in spray paint statues and couldn't
hold the candle to anything the Winston
Churchill ever accomplished in his life
now want to tear down a Winston
Churchill statue to feel good about
themselves very important stuff we're
really doing important things right
we're doing important things like taking
down Gone with the Wind from HBO max
that was very important the the HBO
executives said they didn't have a shred
not a shred of worry or regret about
taking down the Gone with the Wind
taking down Gone with the Wind not at
all no censorship taking it down not not
a shred of regret there are there
episodes of It's Always Sunny in
Philadelphia that have been removed from
Netflix because they deleted episodes
featuring
characters in blackface because all the
jokes must be removed
it's very important you guys are doing
important work you're ending racism it's
really really important
Kyrie Irving over in the NBA is saying
that he doesn't want the NBA players to
play because of systematic racism in the
NBA in the NBA which is last I checked
what 85 percent black
there's systemic racism in the NBA
according to Kyrie Irving he said I
don't support going into Orlando I'm not
with the systemic racism and the BS
something smells a little fishy makes
perfect sense
makes perfect sense so what you should
do is you should deprive all of the NBA
players of the ability to play this year
and make any money that them it to end
systemic racism makes perfect perfect
sense it's all at this point we have we
have reached beyond anything remotely
resembling an actual agenda and we've
gone straight to the virtue signaling my
favorite virtue signaling piece of the
week by the way was a piece from the
Washington Monthly from Elizabeth Austin
it begins like this I threw away my copy
of Gone with the Wind it wasn't easy
the book spent a couple of weeks sitting
recycling adjacent before I came up with
the will to toss it into the bin I held
in my hands one last time and I kissed
the title page where my father had
inscribed to Beth Christmas 1975 and
then I dropped it in the garbage so you
throw him away that your dad and a book
you their dad and ascribe to you that is
a classic of American literature with
all of its flaws and representing a very
flawed perspective throwing the way the
book obviously book burning is the
solution guys the virtue signaling is
very strong you want a virtue signal you
can also apparently you know just go to
other people's houses and if they have a
flag that has a thin blue line that pays
homage to police going to somebody's
house and removing the flags that's
always a very good look as well
there's footage of that going around
over this weekend does any of this have
to do with stopping police brutality or
helping black Americans obviously the
answer is no the answer is obviously no
it's all about so much of this is about
white people feeling good about
themselves seriously like an enormous
amount of this by the way including in
Atlanta where apparently that Wendy's
that was set on fire was set on fire by
a white girl and there was footage of
there's actually a black guy taking
footage of her saying this is nice is
this white girl over here who's burning
down the Wendy's so much of this is
driven by loser
white radical leftists who have taken a
legitimate cause against police
brutality and then perverted it to their
own ends they can feel good about
themselves is that really well done
stuff really really
then okay meanwhile the kovat 19
hypocrisy continues apace it is
unbelievable the sort of gas lighting
that is going on right now is firmly I
mean completely and completely insane
completely crazy okay so over the
weekend there was a black trans lives
matter protest because apparently it's
not just black lives that are an
existential threat in the United States
is black trans lives specifically that
are under existential threat and there
were pictures from the footage from the
the BLM protest I mean this thing was
massive you're talking about like tens
of thousands of people out in the
streets right next to each other no
masks or anything and here's how the
news covered it so the media headlines
well yeah I mean here's the footage you
can see the footage it's crazy it's an
enormous enormous crowd of people you
see a lot of social distancing there do
you I'm not seeing a ton of it so people
basically here's what's happening right
now a lot of people are very bored
honestly like some people aren't
legitimately interested in the cause and
a lot of people are very bored and they
get points for virtue signaling so NBC
News put out these headlines less than
an hour apart first headline rally for
black trans lives for us packed crowd to
Brooklyn Museum Plaza less than an hour
later NBC News
president Trump plans to rally his
supporters next Saturday for the first
time since most of the country was
shuttered by coronavirus but health
experts are questioning that decision
what say it's only bad when Trump does
it right when you're rallying for black
trans lives or something then apparently
is totally fine Co but is no threat
anymore
but if you're president Trump then all
of a sudden the media are on top of the
threat like full-scale the worst in this
case of course is Bill DeBlasio so Bill
DeBlasio apparently over the weekend he
was marching because this is what he
does he's a terrible mayor but he was
marching with people so that was
exciting
he said marching with et CNY or during
today's East Harlem pray and protest I
felt the urgency and pain of this moment
but also confidence that change will
come because of the spirit of this
moment movement and because in this city
we affirm that hashtag black lives
matter so a lot of virtue signaling from
that weird gangly goofy human being also
in other news bill de blasio has
announced that New York City Cova 19
contact tracers are not asking whether
people who have koban 19 have been to
protests not kidding this is according
to the cities at NYC over the last two
weeks Mayor Bill DeBlasio and others
have voiced concerns that packed police
brutality protests across the city could
trigger a new
wave of Kovac 19 infections whether or
not that's the case however remains
unknown and de Blasio's team won't be
trucked directly trying to find out the
hundreds of contact tracers working for
the city under de Blasio's tests and
tres campaign have been instructed not
to ask anyone who has tested positive
for koban 19 whether they recently
attended a demonstration city hall
confirmed to the city no person will be
asked proactively if they attended a
protest said Avery Cohen
a spokesperson for DeBlasio instead they
will try to help them recall context and
individuals they may have exposed like
do you live with anyone in your home
traceurs then asked about close contacts
defined as being within six feet of
another person for at least ten minutes
but they will not ask if you've been to
a rally because of what they don't want
is the headline obviously that the
rallies that de Blasio and Cuomo and the
rest of left have been promoting are
actually like dead center for what is
promoting Kovan 19 at this point you're
starting to see how these headlines
about coping 19 reemerging in major
metropolitan areas be like oh my god how
is this happening well let's see most of
these states reopened like beginning of
May
it is now middle of June so hmm what
could have happened like two weeks ago
about two weeks ago what could have
happened any ideas guys but good news
Andrew Cuomo is on top of it he's
threatening Manhattan and the Hamptons
over lack of social distancing the
Hamptons he tweeted out we have received
25,000 complaints of reopening
violations bars or restaurants that
violate the law can lose their liquor
license people with open containers in
the street can be fine police and
protesters not wearing masks can be fine
local government must enforce the law
weird because you didn't have anything
to say about the protesters for like
five seconds also he says the violation
complaints are predominantly from
Manhattan and the Hamptons
lots of violations of social distancing
parties in the streets restaurants and
bars ignoring laws enforce the law or
there will be state action um I noticed
you have a few rallies like right here
around link it's part of your face right
here there's some rallies like just
right over here like mainly all over
this area there's a lot of rallies
happening there
Andrew Muriel Bowser in DC doing the
same thing she is saying that the
increasing Cova that could hit
Washington DC is due to reopening it's
not due to the fact that there were tens
of thousands of people marching through
DC on her watch while she was painting
black lives matter on the street in
giant yellow paint here she was
yesterday I think it's important though
that we not just look to protest as a
reason why we might be seeing
Spike's across the country because
before these protests we were seeing
spikes I think at least 14 states that
reopened early or that where we saw a
lot of gatherings around Memorial Day
are reporting spikes so the reopening of
America in some cases early has already
generated increases in cases right guys
Memorial Day was Monday May 25th
okay there's money May 25th the rally
started on that Thursday and that
Wednesday and that Thursday so um it's
gonna be real hard to separate that out
but I'm noticing a bit of a narrative
here and then you wonder why people
don't take our public health officials
seriously or our public officials
seriously all legitimacy has been lost
here and should be lost because they're
a joke de Blasio is a joke Bowser's a
joke Cuomo's a joke it's all it's all a
sick joke already we'll be back here
later to do two additional hours of
content otherwise we'll see you here
tomorrow I'm Ben Shapiro this is the Ben
Shapiro show
the Ben Shapiro show is produced by
Colton Haas executive producer Jeremy
boring supervising producer
Mathis Glover and Robert Stirling
assistant director Pavel why douse key
technical producer Austin Stevens
playback and media operated by Nick
Sheehan associate producer Katie Swinton
edited by Adam SIA vets audio is mixed
by Mike or Amina hair and makeup is by
Anika Geneva the Ben Shapiro show is a
daily wire production copyright day Lee
Weyer 2020 released criminals reoffended
let history configures their erasing and
celebrities have had enough check it out
on the Michael Nolan show
[Music]
you